TRUMP'S INSTINCTS VERSUS THE
SWAMP.
OTHER ISSUES ACTUALLY MATTER OUT
THERE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
ANGLE.
DESPITE THE UNLESS MEDIA CHATTER
ABOUT FBI RAIDS AND PORN STAR
PAYMENTS, THERE ARE ACTUALLY FAR
MORE IMPORTANT STORIES THAT ARE
SIMILAR BEING IGNORED BY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
BY THE WAY, THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT MOST AFFECT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IN SPITE OF ALL OF THE SIDESHOW
DRAMA, I HAVE TO TELL YOU
TONIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GETTING REAL RESULTS BY LARGELY
FOLLOWING HIS INSTINCTS.
THINK ABOUT IT.
ON THE IMMIGRATION FRONT, WHEN
ALL THE OTHERS WERE AFRAID,
WELL, TRUMP CALLED FOR SERIOUS
BORDER ENFORCEMENT AND HE NAMED
THE THREAT FACING THE
UNITED STATES.
>> WE WILL END THE SANCTUARY
CITIES THAT HAVE RESULTED IN SO
MANY NEEDLESS DEATHS.
IT'S THE POLICY OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO DISMANTLE,
DECIMATE, AND ERADICATE MS-13.
I TOLD MEXICO VERY STRONGLY
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THESE CARAVANS
THAT ARE COMING UP.
>> Laura: WHAT BECAME OF THAT
CARAVAN?
THAT CARAVAN WAS LARGELY
DISPERSED.
WHATEVER STRAGGLERS MAKE IT TO
THE BORDER, WELL, THEY WILL BE
GRADED BY OUR FRIENDLY MEMBERS
OF THE NATIONAL GUARD.
THEN THERE WAS NORTH KOREA.
THE PUNDIT CLASS ATTACKED
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR DARING TO
THREATEN ROCKET MEN WITH FIRE
AND FURY.
IF, IN FACT, KIM JONG UN
PERSISTED WITH HIS NUCLEAR
AMBITIONS.
NOW NORTH KOREA IS AT THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE AND WILLING TO
DISCUSS DENUCLEARIZATION.
WINNING.
REMEMBER THE CHORUS OF NAYSAYERS
THAT GREETED TRUMP'S
ANNOUNCEMENT TO SLAP TOUGH NEW
TARIFFS ON CHINA?
>> CHINA IS HITTING BACK AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP APPEARED TO
RAISE --
>> WAIT A SECOND.
>> IT IS SUCH A SURPRISE.
WHO COULD HAVE IMAGINED WE WILL
BE PUT IN THIS TERRIBLE
POSITION?
>> SIMPLY SAYING JOBS, JOBS,
JOBS IS AS CONVINCING AS SAYING
TRADE WARS ARE EASY TO WIN.
>> THE PERSON NEGOTIATING THIS
HAS HAS FACTS DAY IN AND DAY OUT
WRONG.
THE PERSON I'M TALKING ABOUT,
MR. PRESIDENT, IS YOU.
>> Laura: MUCH MORE PERSUASIVE
WHEN YOU DO THAT TO THE CAMERA.
WELL, CHINA IS BLINKING ON
TRADE.
PRESIDENT XI JUST ANNOUNCED
CHINA IS GOING TO BE LOWERING
TARIFFS ON AUTO IMPORTS,
INCLUDING THOSE FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
HE ALSO PROMISED TO PROTECT THE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY OF THOSE